Закон президента України Володимира Зеленського,
мета якого реформувати судову систему, набув чинності у листопаді 2019-го.
Закон створює інструменти для очищення та оновлення органів суддівського врядування -
Вищої кваліфікаційної комісії суддів і Вищої ради правосуддя.
Саме вони, на думку активістів, відповідальні за провал з очищенням суддів в країні.
Однак вже через місяць після ухвалення закону,
замість його імплементації, судді знайшли засіб перешкодити реформі
і заблокувати очищення, під яке самі можуть потрапити.
Вони ухвалили положення про проведення конкурсу, які суперечать нормам закону.
Закон передбачає участь міжнародних експертів в роботі двох комісій – конкурсній та етичній.
Конкурсна обиратиме членів нової Вищої кваліфікаційної комісії суддів.
Етична - ініціюватиме звільнення недоброчесних членів ВККС,
Вищої ради правосуддя, а ще суддів Верховного Суду.
В етичну комісію мають входити три міжнародних експерти та три члени ВРП.
Найголовніше полягає в тому, що згідно з законом,
міжнародні експерти мають вирішальний голос при голосуванні за кандидата.
Саме конкурсна комісія має визначити 12 найкращихкандидатів
на місця 12-ти членів ВККС та надати цей список на затвердження Вищій раді правосуддя.
Натомість Вища рада правосуддя
фактично переписала закон і додала туди свої умови, скаржаться активісти.
Зокрема, ВРП вирішила, що оцінювати кандидатів треба виключно за "офіційними джерелами",
а аргументувати - за стандартами кримінального права.
Тобто, без вироку суду комісія не зможе поставити під сумнів кандидата,
який приховує свої статки або живе значно дорожчим життям,
ніж його офіційні доходи, констатують у Центрі протидії корупції.
Замість голосування за кандидатів, членам комісії відвели значно скромнішу роль -
складати рейтинги кандидатів.
Половина оцінки - це результати тестування на знання права.
При чому  ВРП надала собі функцію готувати самі тести та розробляти методики оцінки результатів.
Та навіть виставлені бали кандидатам можуть не стати визначальними,
оскільки Вища рада правосуддя, попри норму закону,
залишила за собою право призначати до ВККС кого захоче,
а не тих, кого рекомендувала конкурсна комісія, повідомляють експерти фундації DEJURE.
Ба більше, положення ВРП надають перевагу кандидатам-суддям,
якщо у кандидатів однакові позиції за рейтингом.
А серед суддів - претендентам із більшим суддівським стажем.
Усе це суперечить закону, бо порушує принцип рівних можливостей.
Окрім того, ВРП вимагає від міжнародних експертів,
щоб вони особисто доводили, що мають вищу освіту і професійний стаж.
У законі йдеться про те, що експертів пропонують
міжнароні та іноземні організації, які і відповідають за кваліфікацію своїх кандидатів.
А також - Вища рада правосуддя висуває додаткові не передбачені законом
вимоги для членів Конкурсної комісії - п'ятирічний стаж.
Також ВРП досі не делегувала своїх представників
до етичної комісії, попри те, що минув місяць з часу початку дії закону.
А без цього комісія не зможе розпочати свою роботу.
В законі чітко прописано, що роль Вищої ради правосуддя у конкурсі до ВККС
зводиться виключно до створення Конкурсної комісії
та призначення членів ВККС, відібраних цією ж комісією.
Саме комісія має самостійно визначити професійний досвід,
знання і якості кандидатів, та обрати переможців.
І аж ніяк не ВРП, яка має просто організувати і забезпечити проведення конкурсу
у передбачений законом спосіб, а не перебирати на себе повноваження конкурсної комісії,
йдеться у повідомленні експертів фундації DEJURE.
Перезавантаження ВККС - один з визначальних кроків у судовій реформі,
адже ця інституція відповідає за якісні кадри в судовій системі.
Попередня спроба перезапуску ВККС за часів Петра Порошенка провалилася.
Стосовно ж Вищої ради правосуддя, то провал її перезавантаження є не меншою загрозою.
Адже вона відповідає за суддів Антикорупційного суду,
а також суддів, які розглядають позови проти парламенту і президента, господарські справи тощо.
За нинішним сценарієм є велика ймовірність,
що перемагатимуть у конкурсі судді, близькі до суддів ВРП
і контрольовані ними, вважають активісти.